our trophy nickname here in Iceland it
was hard to finish the exhibit and
afterwards it left a really bad taste in
my mouth
hi my name is Grace help we do not know
you know your look is different now it's
bright and here at my channel which
means it's time to comment on your
comments because that is something that
I am really sticking to consistency is
not my forte but will is will forte
let's do it over Twitter do use Twitter
I use Twitter
I swear I'm not an alien inside of a
human body pretending to be a human
foxing lady OH - numbers numbers numbers
are popular do not know what a new
person columns on any of my social media
platform I grade the crap out and
welcome to the 5th grade family hates
people but now I great people because
why do you mean when you can be dumb
however notice position which it almost
got through it counter notice new person
I don't know I just get okay everyone is
a new person here we go actual a do two
more like boxxybabee not for you is what
I'm saying to myself I'm looking at
myself in the viewfinder and just say
fast nobody here we're good
let's thank you very solid a not too
deep podcast and trying not to
explosively laugh on that tram is a
challenging one for listening to the
nacho-cheese podcast if you guys haven't
see go to soundcloud nation and listen
to all the episodes or watch them all on
full screen - I really thought this
tweet might have taken a turn I thought
listening to grace elementary podcast
and try not to explosively
diarrhea on the tram is a challenge
might have been what you tweeted but no
glad to know it's laughs bye hey here's
a good challenge I don't listen to not
to deep and not have explosive diarrhea
oh my god that's going to sweep all
nations champ and observers in Persian
camp BAM we're like jelly
estrange step-siblings ooh boo boo that
todrick at I'm not Scottie cider please
get drunk with grace Helbig I'd be so
happy I'm here to provide happiness for
you guys so if that is something that
you need me to do and you need Patti's
guy to do to make you happy I just feel
like we should do that we are Crusaders
for societal happiness some people say
choose happiness I say boost
happiness I don't say that I just I mean
I said it out loud here but as for
Alison's never different number three
lessons will I bring just strange
Stephan's you look great it's a nice
country there are lots of small horses
okay yeah I do think this is a nice
country is horse
Atlantic's from far as I've seen bars I
haven't seen small horses maybe they're
so tiny I can't see them
you got teeny tiny horses on them now
good intagram do you have Instagram I
use Instagram to post photos again not
an alien pretending to be human just
actually trying to have a conversation
if you can't got it a hateful potato
wedges numbers numbers and April potato
is more like the grateful potato handful
I would be so grateful for a hedge maze
made of potatoes you're great Wow Wow
Wow
are you okay are you having a stroke did
you fall face-first on your keyboard and
you're just oh wo wo w it's too late for
me to actually checking on you you left
this comment on a photo from a couple
days ago so I hope you're okay okay okay
Gretchen bad you are rivers Newburgh
aggression bad more like stretching yay
out of here stretch your legs I can get
out here you're a brute you don't need
to know this but today a too many fries
and vomited ah ha ha they were really
good
well I'm glad you seemed really positive
about that although what you ate too
many fries in your mom and had no one
needs to hear about those kind of
consequences from potatoes okay so can
you keep that to yourself ah what is our
different never surrender what is ours
more like what is real are we living in
an alternate dimension is kind of an
illusion are you seeing what I'm seeing
do a good where is it where is anything
where are we right now are we on earth
are we on some like figment of a more
collective imagination that penis museum
may be crazy the museum was the boners
that broke this camel's back not that it
usually would use you to buy would you
campaign to earn numbers new version
traffic more like [ __ ] Nick you were
good I didn't make up a little all
things in moderation and hope you washed
your hands before you left I comment
I don't get your keyword unless you're
at like a public library or something
and I'm like you know be a gentleman
David underscore different universe new
person David underscore Marling's David
never scored a saint justice Christian
beautifully your boobs are monkey thank
you so much right did you hear that
David underscore with their profile
picture because I think he might be too
afraid to show the world who his things
that you are wonky and he thought is
enough to leave a comment on a video
someone he's never met before and that's
why I just need you to know that your
one key okay message received
Morgan subsequently perseveres and more
intense than like Morgan Spencer's gift
shop member that that was a place that
if you were cool when you're 15 you walk
to the back you tell all this black
light dick paraphernalia I went to a
penis museum today that might have been
the Spencer's gift shop advice so much
mail dick humor great Wow seagulls are
on every continent Google told me no
Google didn't tell you I told you that
Google just wanted to feel like they
were part of it so cool job Google this
channel is edutainment
please don't restrict any of my videos
Google mr. Turks to Urkel moversmovers
and mr. Turks purple more like mister
you don't seem like a fun party yet I
mean do a great watermelon haven't got
the muster to blow tones on the phone
okay thank you son the alien pretending
to be a human here okay I did for coming
here in your comments thanks so much for
watching if you like these kind of
videos give them a thumbs up I don't do
the memory by day if that's what you
want only on social media at grace
Helbig across the board and subscribe to
this YouTube channel I make videos
Monday Wednesday and Friday sometime and
other than that I don't know oh I would
be so grateful for a hedge maze major
potaters I've got a little emotional